welcome to free pilot training i'm josh
and today i'm going to explain in detail
how to plan your first vfr cross-country
flight
this lesson will explain the tools you
need to plan the flight and how to fill
out a vfr navigation log because you're
going to need to know how to do that if
you want to get your private pilot's
license
[Music]
to get started today we need to pull out
a vfr sectional and our plotter the
first thing we're going to do is use the
plotter to draw a straight line between
the departure airport and the arrival
airport now unless you're specifically
trying to avoid restricted air space or
something like that you really want to
draw a straight line between these two
points you don't want to pick waypoints
until after you've done this zigzagging
to your destination like this is going
to make it difficult to fill out your
nav log and it's going to make things
more difficult when you actually go to
flight across country as well today i'm
flying across country from venita
municipal airport which is my home
airport to monet regional over missouri
so i'll just use my plotter to draw a
straight line between these two airports
now that we've done that let's pick some
waypoints that we're going to be able to
see from the air as we fly over them you
really need to have a vfr waypoint every
10 to 20 miles but if you go slightly
over or slightly under because you can't
find anything good that's fine
let's see the fingers on a big lake like
this make a great waypoint so i'll pick
this one first
then for the next one i'll use this
curvy highway on the other side of the
lake you want to make sure that you're
picking out waypoints that you're going
to be able to see this one might be a
little tough but i should be able to
spot this bridge and follow it up to my
location so it should work out for us
and i call that a funneling feature for
the next point i'm going to use this
little victor airway it looks like i'll
be on the 342 radial from the razorback
vortec when i hit this now normally i
just choose this little airport right
here because that's going to be really
easy to see but i just wanted to show
you how to throw these vors in the nav
log in case you wanted to use them when
you plan your cross-country flight so
i'll go ahead and mark this on the
sectional here that should just about do
it for the waypoints on this cross
country and by the way it's better to
use waypoints that are kind of off to
the side and not directly underneath you
so you can see them better alright let's
go ahead and pull out our vfr nav log
and start filling that out
this particular nav log comes from
jeppesen and it's kind of the standard
for vfr flight planning i recommend this
one because it's probably the most
common nav log out there
anyway let's start by putting our
departure airport then our first
waypoint will actually not be the one we
marked on the sectional it's going to be
our top of climb we'll discuss that more
here in just a minute but for now we'll
just put a toc here
now i've got the finger of our lake then
the curvy road then we said we're going
to use this 342 radial from the
razorback vortec and this nav log's kind
of nice because it actually has a place
where you can put your vor frequency the
ident letters are will actually go here
but i like to put that in the checkpoint
name and the radial in here so we don't
have to search for it on our sectional
when we get there and last of all before
our destination we have one other
waypoint we want to add and that's our
top of descent and we'll put a little
tod to signify that
then our destination will be the last
waypoint next we need to find our true
course this is the actual ground track
that we're going to be flying in
relation to true north we'll figure out
what the heading we'll be flying here is
in just a minute but we need to start
with a true course for now now every
plotter works a little bit differently
but this one is modeled after one you
can buy from gleim and if you didn't
know how to pronounce that brand you're
welcome and if you like the way this
plotter works i'll put a link in the
description so you can purchase one from
amazon but anyway for this one all you
have to do is lay the plotter on your
course line and align those little marks
on the protractor section and the center
piper with a line of longitude lines of
longitude are the black lines with the
little hash marks that run up and down
the globe all these lines of longitude
are perfectly aligned with true north as
i've explained in other videos and all
we have to do is lay our plotter on our
course line and one of these and check
the course line under the line of
longitude okay so let's lay the plotter
out on our course on the vfr sectional
and when we do it looks like our true
course is exactly 0.70 degrees let's go
back to our nav log and fill in this
information we'll put it right here in
these boxes for the course root then
we'll come over here to these columns
labeled tc which stands for true course
and we'll put in all these as well
these boxes over here are just a
starting point so we can calculate our
heading for each leg and you can see now
how much work you just added for
yourself if you're planning a route that
zigzagged all the way to your
destination
next let's choose an altitude anytime
you're flying above 3000 feet agl we
need to fly the correct vfr cruising
altitudes if we're flying on the east
side of the compass in other words from
zero degrees to 179 we need to be at an
odd altitude plus 500 feet
if we're flying on the west side of the
compass or a 180-359
we need to be at an even altitude plus
500. i remember this with two handy
words neod and sweeven northeast
altitudes are odd plus 500 and south and
west altitudes are even plus 500 the
word sweeven just sounds so cool doesn't
it i just want to use it in normal
conversations you'd be pretty sweet and
if you hit that like button for me
anyway our true course is zero seven
zero so unfortunately we're not sweeping
on this flight we're neod so for my
cruise altitude today i'll pick 5500 msl
and i'll come back over here to our nav
log and fill in our altitude information
then the top of descent line i'll go
ahead and throw our pattern altitude in
here because i'm planning to enter a
downwind and my pattern altitude over at
monet is 2400 feet msl next we have our
wind data and i'll grab this information
from our winds of loft charts i have a
video specifically on where to find
these charts and how to read them so if
you haven't watched that i'll put a link
in the description and you can watch
that after this video if you want but
right now i want to focus on filling out
this nav log and how to use this
information to calculate a few things
when i look at the cover page for the
wins of charts it looks like the closest
airport with wind sensors to my root of
flight is going to be springfield or sgf
so we'll use their wind data but
sometimes europe may go through airspace
with multiple sensors so if you want to
be accurate you should use the closest
sensor on each leg of your flight now
when you look at this chart you can see
that there's not a 5 500 foot altitude
block so we're just going to use the
column that's closest to our cruising
altitude which is 6 000 feet
from veneta to our top of climb let's
use the 3000 foot column because we're
going to be climbing through 3000 feet
on the way up and it's roughly halfway
between the two it looks like near
springfield winds are 090 at 14 knots so
we'll throw that over here in our nav
log
notice we don't have temperatures in the
three thousand foot columns so let's
estimate one using the six thousand foot
column a standard lapse rate is two
degrees celsius drop every thousand feet
of altitude that you gain so with a
temperature of eight degrees celsius at
six thousand feet i know my temperature
is going to be somewhere around 14
degrees or so here so let's go ahead and
throw this in our nav log then for the
rest of these wins and temps we'll use
the data from the 6 000 foot column so
let's look back at the 6000 foot section
on the window off chart it looks like we
have winds of 190 at seven knots and a
temperature of eight degrees celsius so
let's go ahead and throw these over here
as well and for our top of descent
halfway down is closer to three thousand
feet so let's go ahead and use that wind
data again now it's really important to
try and make this as accurate as
possible because the main reason we're
doing this is to make sure that we're
going to have enough fuel to get to our
destination
so if for some reason you were cruising
right in the middle of these two
altitudes you may want to average or
interpolate these winds to be more
accurate i'll show you how to do that
really quick if for some reason you're
cruising right at four thousand five
hundred feet we know the winds in
springfield are zero nine zero at
fourteen knots at three thousand feet
and one nine zero at seven knots at six
thousand to find the average let's start
with the wind direction all we need to
do is add one nine zero and ninety
together and then divide that number by
two so our wind direction here at four
thousand five hundred feet should be one
four zero degrees now we'll just do the
same thing to our wind speed as well
let's add 14 and 7 for a total of 21 and
divide that by 2 to get an average of
10.5
let's just round that up to 11 knots so
our winds at 4500 feet msl are 140 at 11
knots and that's how easy it is to
average your wins and get your numbers a
little bit more accurate if you aren't
exactly in the middle of a group of
numbers interpolating is going to be the
most accurate method but once again we
don't really need to do this on this
cross-country flight today because five
thousand five hundred feet msl is close
enough to six thousand feet
our calculations still should be pretty
accurate and by the way all this winds
aloft information is in relation to true
north we're going to be converting
everything at the same time when we go
to find our magnetic heading next we
need to come up with our true air speed
to do that let's pull out our poh and
look at the performance section in newer
airplanes this will be in section 5 and
we're looking for tables labeled cruise
performance if you're looking at the poh
in an older airplane you'll notice that
the cruise data is often just thrown in
there wherever it fits so you might have
to do a little digging
a lot of times there's a lot less
information in these older ones as well
so you'll just have to work with what
you got and get those numbers as close
as you can anyway the first thing we
need to do here is pick a cruise
altitude then pick an rpm we want to fly
in order to be really accurate we need
to know the pressure altitude we're
going to be flying at and before we can
do that we need to know the altimeter
setting of where we're going to be
flying and the temperature at that
altitude we already know the temperature
because we wrote those down in the
column over here but to get the
altimeter setting you're going to have
to grab that from the current metar now
you won't find altimeter settings on the
taps so if you're going to want to fill
this out the day before you're going to
have to find a good media gram somewhere
that gives you an altimeter prediction
or you could just use the actual
altitude of 5500 feet msl one of my
favorite mediagram websites to use is
called windy.com not only do they have
altimeter predictions several days in
advance but you can also get a pretty
accurate depiction of the clouds you can
expect pretty far in advance as well for
today let's say our altimeter is 3003.
there's a couple ways we can calculate
our pressure altitude but the easiest
way is to take the standard altimeter
setting and subtract the current
altimeter setting so in this example we
take 29.92 inches minus 30.03 inches
this gives us minus 0.11 remember on a
standard day the pressure drops one inch
of mercury every thousand feet so all we
have to do is move this decimal over
three places to turn this into thousands
of feet when we do that we can see that
the difference is minus 110 feet so to
get our pressure altitude we add 5500
feet and negative 110
that gives us
5390 feet for our pressure altitude as
you can see it didn't really make a huge
difference for us today we're still
closest to the 6000 foot line so we're
just going to use that one for today but
if the pressure altitude was really low
or really high this can make a huge
difference in your performance
once again if you want to get these
numbers perfect you could interpolate
between the 4 000 foot charts and the
6000 foot charts i wouldn't average them
because you're closer to the 6 000 foot
area but interpolation is an option if
you're super picky i might discuss
interpolation in a future episode if i
get enough people to request it now
let's go ahead and pick an rpm we want
to fly
basically all you're doing here is
deciding if you want to get there faster
or burn less fuel
max rpm doesn't really get you there
much faster so let's pick 2400 rpms to
save a little bit of fuel next let's
choose the appropriate temperature on
most performance charts you'll notice
that the temperature is given in
reference to standard temperature
if you remember from past lessons
standard temperature is 15 degrees
celsius
so we might need to do just a little bit
of math here okay so at our cruise
altitude we said that the temperature
should be eight degrees celsius
standard temperature is 15 and 20 below
standard is negative five so which
temperature are we closer to
well we're a little closer to the
standard section here so let's use this
data
if i wanted to get the numbers exact
once again we could interpolate this
data but i'm not super concerned about
doing that today now you can see that at
this pressure altitude this power
setting and this temperature our basic
horsepower is 57 percent our true air
speed is 108 knots and our fuel burn is
going to be 8.2 gallons per hour when it
comes to these charts one thing you want
to do is really check to make sure
there's no notes that apply to you for
this particular cruise chart it looks
like we need to make sure that we
remember to lean the mixture once we get
to our cruise altitude and if we're not
exactly 2 550 pounds these numbers could
be off a little bit one way or the other
all right let's put these numbers in our
nav log up here in the notes section
this is a great place to put all the
data you've been collecting so you know
where all your calculations came from
let's see we said the altimeter was 3003
and that makes our pressure altitude 5
390 feet the power setting we want to
use is 2400 rpm our basic horsepower is
going to be 57
our true airspeed will be 108 knots and
the fuel burn will be 8.2 gallons per
hour okay so we'll skip the first one
but let's go ahead and throw our true
air speed in all these lines now this
isn't the air speed you're going to be
seeing on your air speed indicator this
is basically how fast you're moving
through the air around you to find our
indicated air speed we need to dig out
our flight computer and our poh
i'm using an e6b today because that's
the most basic and common flight
computer there is if you can use this
one you can use just about any flight
computer you'll probably hear me refer
to this as a whiz wheel but there's no p
joke insinuated here that's just what
i've been taught to call them now this
is kind of a cool app it's called flight
computer sim this is a free version you
can get from the app store but they also
have a paid version that's like four
dollars and it's kind of fun to use if
you don't want to buy a real wiz wheel
okay so anyway before we can come up
with our indicated airspeed we need to
first determine our calibrated air speed
when you first glance at one of these
things it may seem kind of complicated
but they're really not as bad as they
seem and if you ever forget how to use
them almost all of them have the
instructions written on them okay so the
first thing we're going to do is
calculate our calibrated air speed to do
that we need to start with our
temperature and our pressure altitude we
said earlier that our temperature was 8
degrees and on this scale 8 is too small
to read so let's round up to 10 degrees
now we'll just rotate this 10 degree
mark to our pressure altitude of 5 390
feet once again that's a little too
specific so we'll just use 5500 now that
our wiz wheel's set we can read our true
air speed on the outer scale and the
calibrated air speed will be on the
inner scale so let's find 108 knots on
the outer scale here's 105 106 107 and
there it is 108 knots now we can read
our calibrated air speed under that it
looks like about 98 knots is what we can
expect so let's write this in right here
to find our indicated air speed we need
to pull out the poh and look at the
airspeed calibration chart make sure
you're using the normal static source
and not the alternate static chart this
will give you the wrong data let's see
we're going to be flaps up and the
closest air speed to 98 is 97 with a
calibrated air speed of 97 knots we're
going to be expecting an indicated air
speed of 100 knots so with a calibrated
air speed of 98 i'm betting our
indicated air speed will be around 101
knots and i'll just make a note of this
on my nav log so i can make sure we're
traveling the speed we're expecting with
these power settings if our indicated
airspeed isn't close to what we
calculated this can have a big impact on
how much fuel will burn on this trip and
speaking of that we know how much fuel
per hour we should be burning so let's
go ahead and put that in the gallons per
hour section right here all right now we
can go back and grab our climb data once
again you'll find this data in section 5
and it's usually labeled climb
performance or something like that
as you can see this one is labeled time
fuel and distance to climb at 2 550
pounds this is the only chart for this
particular airplane they're only giving
you this weight so you know that if
you're heavier your airplane isn't going
to perform quite as well notice these
conditions in order for this chart to be
accurate we need to climb out with our
flaps up at full throttle and the
temperature needs to be standard or 15
degrees celsius
additionally this climb out starts from
sea level if you're starting from a
higher pressure altitude it's not going
to take you quite as long and you'll be
using slightly less fuel so i would go
ahead and use these numbers because
they're going to be conservative and
it'll give you a little extra fuel okay
so we know that we're going up to 5 390
feet pressure altitude so let's use this
line closest to 5000 feet so now if we
want to use this chart properly we need
to climb out at an indicated air speed
of 73 knots and that's going to give us
a rate of climb at 550 feet per minute
we also know that it's going to take us
eight minutes to get to our top of climb
and we'll use 1.9 gallons in the climb
and we should be able to reach our
altitude in 10 miles let's throw this
climb data in our notes but before we
put it down in the actual nav log we
need to look at a couple things down
here in our notes one of the first
things it says is that we need to add
1.4 gallons of fuel for engine start
taxi and takeoff
okay so let's add that 1.4 to our climb
fuel of 1.9 and that gives us a total of
3.3 gallons of total fuel that we're
going to burn to get up to our cruise
altitude and now we'll go ahead and put
this in the fuel section over here next
this note just lets you know that if
you're going to be flying at a pressure
altitude greater than 3000 feet you need
to lean the mixture if you want to get
the maximum performance out of your
engine
next we see that for every 10 degrees
above standard we need to increase these
numbers by 10 percent
it's slightly below standard today so we
don't have to worry about that next it
says that these distances are based on
zero wind so we need to calculate our
ground speed in order to get the actual
distance to our top of climb and to find
that we need to know our true airspeed
which of course they didn't give us
they gave us our indicated airspeed on
this chart and we'll have to break out
the poh and the whiz wheel really quick
and work backwards from the problem we
solved earlier to find that okay so we
know that our indicated airspeed is 73
knots now we need to find our calibrated
air speed the first step in converting
back and forth from true and indicated
airspeed is always to find the
calibrated airspeed first and once again
to do that we need to dig out that
airspeed calibration chart from the poh
once again we're flaps up it looks like
70 knots indicated equals 70 knots
calibrated and 80 knots indicated equals
78 knots calibrated in this example 73
is so close to 70 that i would estimate
our calibrated air speed is probably
pretty close to 73 knots you could
interpolate between these two numbers
but i don't really see a reason to do
that so we'll go ahead and say our
calibrated air speed is 73 knots let's
pull out that whiz wheel again
now your true air speed is going to be
changing as you're climbing so what i
would recommend doing is taking the
pressure altitude about halfway up
through your climb this is going to make
your calculations a little more accurate
so we'll say my pressure altitude is
2500 feet because that's roughly half of
our pressure altitude and we know the
temperature is about 10 degrees here so
now we'll find the 73 knots calibrated
air speed on the inner part of the whiz
wheel and we'll read our true air speed
on the outer ring it looks like our true
air speed is about 76 knots let's go
ahead and throw that in our nav log now
okay before we can calculate our ground
speed for all these legs we need to talk
about winds for a minute we're going to
need this information to take our course
and turn that into a heading we can fly
and that information will also determine
our ground speed we know our true course
is 070 degrees now we need to use that
wind data we got earlier to turn that
into a true heading our true heading is
the heading we will fly in relation to
true north in order to stay on course
all the way to our destination we're
still going to have to do a couple more
things if we want to use our heading
indicator to stay on course but this is
where we need to start to come up with
our true heading we need to pull out our
wiz wheel again this time we'll be
looking at the winding side or the back
side okay we know that during our climb
out our winds are 0-9-0 at 14 knots
first let's start by sliding the center
scale right at the 100 mark then we'll
put our wind direction under the true
course and make a mark for our wind
speed my wind speed was 14 knots so i'll
put this mark 14 from the hundred
then we can rotate the wheel until it
hits our true course of zero seven zero
then the last thing we need to do here
is to slide the mark we made earlier
down to our true air speed which we said
earlier was 76 knots now it's important
that we move the mark down to the 76
knot line and not the middle marker your
calculations are not going to be right
if you do it that way
now we can read our correction angle
right here these are in increments of 2
so it looks like my wind correction
angle is going to be 0 to 3 degrees
if your correction angle is on the left
side of the scale you'll subtract that
from your course and if it's on the
right you'll want to add that
if you ever forget the nav log tells you
what to do right here so that means we
need to add three degrees and that gives
me a true heading of zero seven three
but before we finish this heading stuff
while we still have the whiz wheel set
up let's grab our ground speed and all
we need to do to get that is to look
under the center mark so to me it looks
like our ground speed is about 63 knots
and we'll go ahead and put that right
here in the ground speed column for our
climb out data let's go back to working
on our heading the next step is finding
our magnetic heading and to do that
we'll take a closer look at our vfr
sectional to check our magnetic
variation it looks like the closest
isogonic line is over here near tulsa
with a variation of 2 degrees east so
we'll subtract 2 degrees because east is
least and west is best and once again if
you forget they give you the answer
right here so we'll subtract 2 to get a
magnetic heading of 071 degrees
now we need to know our magnetic
deviation and every airplane is
different so we need to look at the
compass card on our airplane to get this
information it looks like on my airplane
i need to steer a zero five eight if i
want to get a zero six zero heading and
that's the closest heading to the one we
need to fly so we'll use this one so in
order to be accurate we need to subtract
two degrees from our magnetic heading of
zero seven one that gives us the final
course heading of zero six nine and this
is the heading we're going to be flying
for this leg let's do this together one
more time with the next leg at our
cruise altitude so we know for sure that
you completely understand how to do it
okay so we said the winds here at cruz
we're 190 at 7 and our true airspeed is
going to be 108 knots once again we'll
start with the center of our whiz wheel
on 100 and rotate the compass card over
to our wind direction there it is 190
then we'll put a mark seven knots up
because that's our wind speed let's spin
the whiz wheel over to our true course
zero seven zero then slide the mark up
to our true air speed not the center now
we simply read our ground speed on the
center mark and it looks like our ground
speed is going to be 111 knots now we
can just throw this in our nav log
everywhere else because our true
airspeed true course and wind data is
the same for the rest of the route it
looks like our wind correction angle is
three degrees to the right again sorry
guys i didn't plan that let's go ahead
and add that to zero seven zero to get a
true heading of zero seven three
then i'll subtract my variation of two
degrees to get zero seven one and by the
way it is possible for your flight to go
through more than one isogonic line so
just make sure you're paying attention
and you update this variation if you go
to an area where it's different
anyway we'll look at our compass
correction card again zero seven zero is
closest to zero six zero and it looks
like for a heading in that area we need
to subtract two degrees and that's going
to give us a course of zero six nine for
the rest of our legs this is kind of
rare usually you'll have one or two
heading changes so pay attention to this
now think of how many of these
calculations you'd have to do if you
zigzag to your destination anyway i'll
go ahead and fill in the rest of this
wind data so we can talk about the rest
of this stuff
now we need to find our distances for
this trip to do that let's go back to
the vfr sectional and pull out our
plotter before we start taking
measurements i want to point out a
couple of things
first make sure you're using the correct
scale some plotters have a lot of
different scales on them so they can be
used with other types of charts but
anytime you use the vfr sectional you
need to use the one to five hundred
thousand vfr sectional scale you'll also
notice that you have a choice between
statue and nautical miles the statute
model was designed for airplanes with
airspeed indicators that read out in
miles per hour and the nautical mile
side was designed for airplanes with
airspeed indicators that read out in
knots now your whiz wheel will calculate
all these speeds and stuff exactly the
same for miles per hour as it will for
knots the problem is that your wind
speeds are given in knots so if you're
going to be using miles per hour you
either need to convert your winds to
miles per hour or you can calculate
everything in knots and just write down
your expected indicated air speed in
miles per hour
if you do this just remember that all
your calculations and the numbers you're
using are going to be a knots then
you're only going to be using your
airspeed indicator to check your
indicated air speed to make sure you're
close to your calculations that's
probably what i would do but just play
around with it and see what works best
for you that's why i hate airspeed
indicators that are in miles per hour
anyway another thing you want to be
careful about is that if you leave these
plotters in a hot car or something they
can shrink and your scale can be off be
careful with these things and keep them
in a cool dark place so they don't get
messed up and your numbers will be
correct the last thing i want to mention
is that on most of these zero is not at
the end so if you're not paying
attention to that these things can bite
you okay enough of all that let's
measure this thing
first we'll measure the total distance
looks to mean like it's about 58
nautical miles and we'll just put that
number here in the first box on our nav
log
then we have our distance to the top of
climb which we said was 10 miles and now
that we know that we can put that here
in this box and we can also put a mark
here on our chart it looks like our
first waypoint is another two miles past
that so this is a really short leg and
that's fine i want a short leg on the
first one so i can find that waypoint on
the climb out and start my cross country
on a known point our next waypoint is
our crooked road i'm reading 9 nautical
miles here
then we have our 342 radial off the
razorback vortec i'm reading 20 nautical
miles here on this one then last but not
least we have our top of descent for
this what i like to do is determine how
fast i want to descend from my cruise
altitude down to my pattern altitude
somewhere between 500 to 1000 feet per
minute is a good rate of descent
for today i'll choose a thousand feet
per minute now we know our cruise
altitude is five thousand five hundred
feet msl and the pattern altitude at
monet is two thousand four hundred feet
so if we take five thousand five hundred
feet and subtract two thousand four
hundred from it then we get three
thousand one hundred feet we need to
lose in the descent now we need to find
out how many minutes it will take for us
to get down those 3100 feet 3100 feet
divided by 1000 feet per minute is 3.1
minutes so it's going to take us 3.1
minutes to get down to a pattern
altitude at a thousand feet per minute
so to be safe let's call it three
minutes and 15 seconds
and now we can put this in the column
labeled ete which stands for estimated
time and root but how far is that
now we could use a wiz will to calculate
this but a faster way is to use the
sixty to one rule
we said that we're going 111 knots
ground speed so all we have to do is
divide that by 60 to get our speed and
nautical miles per minute
111 divided by 60 equals 1.85 nautical
miles a minute so if we're traveling at
1.85 nautical miles a minute we simply
multiply times our 3.1 minutes to see
that in 3.1 minutes we will have
traveled just under five and three
quarters nautical miles let's round that
up to six and throw that right here in
our distance then we'll go ahead and
throw in those other distances we
measured a few minutes ago and for the
last one we need to do just a little bit
of math now we said our total distance
was 58 nautical miles 58 minus 10 is 48
then 48 minus 2 is 46
then 46 minus 9 equals 37.
next 37 minus 20 equals 17. now let's
subtract our top of descent from that
now we know we need to start descending
six miles away
so 17 minus six is 11 so our second to
last leg should be 11 miles long let's
go back over to our vfr sectional and
see if this is the case
first i'll make my top of descent six
miles from the airport then i'll take a
quick measurement
that looks close enough to me so our
distances are good to go and six minus
six is zero so i'll just go ahead and
throw that in here
okay so now i want to point out a couple
things in these upper blocks these are
the ground speeds that we calculated we
won't know our actual ground speed until
we get in the plane and calculate that
ourselves so these boxes are going to
remain empty until we go fly now we need
to input our estimated time and route
our estimated time of arrival and our
fuel information and just like our
actual ground speed we won't know our
actual time and route and our actual
time of arrival until we get in the
actual plane and that is an actual fact
okay let's start with our climb out to
find our estimated time in route we need
to know our ground speed and our
distance to the top of climb let's pull
out our flight computer to do these
calculations we said that we're going 63
knots ground speed and by the way timing
calculations are always based off of
ground speed that's the speed we're
actually traveling over the ground
that's why we use it anyway let's rotate
the flight computer until the arrow
points to 63 knots on the outer ring
then we simply find our distance on the
outer ring which we said was 10 miles
then we read the time in minutes under
that when we look at this inner ring it
looks like the climb out should take us
9.5 minutes so we'll call that 9 minutes
and 30 seconds as a quick sanity check i
know that i'm going just over one
nautical mile a minute so i should get
there a little faster than 10 minutes so
9 minutes and 30 seconds makes sense so
i'll go ahead and throw that time right
here in our nav log
for the next leg this one is only two
nautical miles long and now we're flying
at 111 knots ground speed let's rotate
the arrow to 111 knots on the outer
scale then look for a 2 on the outer
ring as you can see there isn't one so
we need to use this 20 and remember if i
remove a decimal from the outer scale i
need to remove one from the inner scale
as well when i read this i'm getting
about 10.8 so i'll move the decimal over
to get 1.08 minutes let's do another
quick sanity check with the 60 to 1 rule
i'm going 111 knots so that's about 1.85
nautical miles a minute
two miles divided by 1.85 nautical miles
a minute is just over 1.08 so once again
that makes sense so let's turn .08 into
seconds by multiplying times 60 looks
like 4.8 so we'll call that five seconds
so this leg should be one minute and
five seconds and we'll throw that over
here in our nav log i'll do one more for
you then we'll move on
this next leg is nine miles and we're
still going 111 knots so our flight
computer is already set up we just need
to find nine miles on the outer scale
then i'll take a look at the inner scale
to see that it's going to take me 4.85
minutes once again i'm going roughly
1.85 nautical miles a minute so 9
divided by 1.85 nautical miles a minute
is just over 4.85 so this is perfect and
0.85 minutes is 51 seconds so this leg
will be 4 minutes and 51 seconds long
and once again we'll log this
information over here and since i'm nice
i'll go ahead and fill in the rest of
this information for you so we can look
at our estimated time of arrival okay so
now what you're supposed to do is
something that i think is a complete
waste of time you're supposed to put
your intended takeoff time right here
and then add the minutes and seconds
onto that to come up with the time that
you're supposed to arrive now you're
more than welcome to do this if you want
but these numbers almost never work out
because you would have to time your
ground ops perfectly to get these
numbers to work right so if you want
something that's just a little more
useful i would recommend adding these
numbers up and coming up with the total
time that it's going to take you to get
to each individual point now this is
going to be a lot more accurate as long
as you hack a clock as soon as you take
off and if you use this method you won't
have to remember to reset the clock
every time you fly over a waypoint
in addition to that we know that it's
going to take exactly 35 minutes and 26
seconds to get to our destination so i
can just add that to my takeoff time if
i need that number for some reason so in
this example i know that i'm going to
reach my destination at exactly 11 35
and 26 seconds local
see how much better that is okay now
let's find out how much fuel we're going
to be burning we already know that we're
going to be burning 3.3 gallons for the
climb and remember this includes our 1.4
gallons of start taxi and takeoff fuel
the rest of these we're going to
calculate based on the time we'll be
flying each leg and the gallons per hour
we found earlier and if you remember we
said that would be 8.2 gallons per hour
based on the numbers we came up with in
the poh okay so we know our first leg is
one minute and five seconds long let's
dig out our flight computer and see how
much fuel will burn in that amount of
time
first i'll set 8.2 on the outer scale
then i'll find 1 minute and 5 seconds on
the inner scale across from that on the
outer ring we'll read how many gallons
we burned it looks like we burned 0.15
gallons let's make sure that passes the
sniff check
if we take 8.2 gallons per hour and
divide that by 60 we get
0.1367 gallons of fuel burn per minute
then we multiply that times 1.08 minutes
and that gives us 0.148 gallons of fuel
we're going to burn
i'd say that's pretty stinking close and
what i like to do when i get weird
numbers like this is i'll round up to
the nearest 10th gallon to be
conservative so let's call this 0.2
gallons and put that in our nav log
our computer should already be set up so
let's calculate the next leg at 4
minutes and 51 seconds
glance here at the inner scale at 4.85
minutes and move over to the outer scale
to see that we should have burned about
.66 gallons once again 8.2 gallons an
hour is roughly 0.1367
and that times our 4.85 minutes is 0.663
gallons let's call this .7 gallons
burned on this one let's do one more of
these the next leg is 10 minutes and 48
seconds so let's find 10.8 minutes on
the inner scale and look across from
there to find 1.48 gallons 10.8 times
our 0.1367 gallons per minute would be
1.476 gallons so this one is once again
perfect and we'll call this 1.5 gallons
and as you can see by rounding up this
is just giving us a little extra cushion
on the gas it doesn't hurt to do this
you never know when you're going to need
that extra little bit of slop and once
again i'll go ahead and finish these up
for you and now we just need to do a
little bit of math to make sure we're
going to have enough fuel for this trip
i would start by putting your usable
fuel up here remember just because your
airplane can hold 56 gallons that
doesn't mean you have 56 gallons of fuel
you can use you need to check your poh
and make sure you're calculating your
fuel reserves based on your usable fuel
now we need to subtract these line by
line until we get to the bottom and see
how much we end up with
now one thing we didn't add in here is
the time and fuel it takes in the
traffic pattern to play things safe i
would say a normal traffic pattern
usually takes an additional 10 minutes
or so to fly
i probably wouldn't use this for timing
purposes but you may want to consider
adding 10 minutes worth of fuel for fuel
planning purposes i've already run the
numbers and it looks like for 10 minutes
at 8.2 gallons per hour we should use
another 1.4 gallons in the pattern
now we can see that we should land with
44.5 gallons of fuel and if you want you
can add these numbers up to see that
this trip will only burn about 8.5
gallons total
remember we need to land with 30 minutes
of additional fuel during the day and 45
minutes at night so how many gallons
would that be
well we said that we're burning 8.2
gallons per hour so cut that in half
we need to land with no less than 4.1
gallons of fuel during the day then at
night just add half of that to get 6.15
gallons and personally i would never let
it get that low
in this particular airplane i probably
wouldn't let it get any less than 8
gallons during the day and 10 at night
but that's my personal preference now
the rest of these boxes are just little
handy places to put the rest of the
information you might need during flight
you don't have to do this but i
recommend trying it out if you're going
to go through all the work of filling
out one of these nav logs anyways then
this nav log can just go on your knee
board and all that information is right
at your fingertips now just like some of
the other information you won't be able
to fill out all this data until you get
into the actual airplane and you go to
fly the cross country but on the back of
this nav log there's going to be a
couple handy things you might want to
fill in before the day of the flight
back here you can throw in your metar
data and you can also throw in the
forecasted weather which would be your
tafs you'll also find a place for your
winds aloft and the icing level in that
area i'm sure you remember why that's
important there's also a few spots here
to put significant weather that you
think might be a factor on your route of
flight back here you'll also find a
place for nodems that you think might be
a problem and even a little reminder of
how to make a pi rip then last but not
least if you want to file flight plan
that form is here as well and as you
probably already know i've already
covered that in detail in my lesson on
flight service stations made easy
i hope you enjoyed this video i did my
best to make it as detailed as i
possibly could in my next videos i hope
to go into a lot more detail on how to
use a flight computer and how to use
this nav log in flight to make sure
you're gonna land with plenty of fuel
when that video is available i'll put it
right here so you can keep on studying
see
position